the country is already being tested in
many ways by the coronavirus
we've got an economic crisis we've got a
reckoning on systemic racism and now
we are being tested once again the last
thing we need on what could be one of
the strongest storms
ever to hit this country her name is
hurricane laura she made landfall as a
category 4
near cameron louisiana at one o'clock
this morning local time
maximum sustained winds were recorded at
150 miles an hour
hundreds of thousands have already lost
power
on a day including storm surges
that forecasters predicted would be
unsurvivable for people
who did not evacuate tony is in lake
charles louisiana this morning
which is about 30 miles from where the
storm came ashore tony good morning
hey good morning gail good morning
anthony you're going to have to bear
with us because we're having a little
bit of trouble hearing you
and we've also had an extremely long
night here in lake charles where we just
found out that the
eye of this storm the strongest storm to
hit this area on record we believe
passed directly over the location where
i am standing
right now in lake charles 30 miles
inland
let me tell you why that is particularly
scary we are about
30 minutes before sunrise here which
means somewhere out in the darkness over
my shoulder
there is still an as yet untallied level
of damage in the surrounding area
and if the worst of the forecasts are
accurate an
uncounted number of dead as well if it's
any indication of what we may see when
the sun comes up
this hotel where we are it's a modern
hotel it's a new hotel it is largely
hurricane proof and nevertheless we have
lost pieces of the roof if you look
behind me
you can see the pool deck here is
scrambled the tops of trees are
sheared off in my hotel room
itself in the middle of the night i was
awoken by a shattered pane of glass
i had to evacuate along with many other
workers here
oil and refinery workers who are
sheltering here before checking on the
plants
while also worrying and this is the big
thing about their own homes
the job site is one thing but then
there's a condition
of their own property and their own
loved ones to get a broader perspective
from what we're seeing right here in
lake charles because every foot can make
a difference in a storm like this one
i want to go to omar villafranca who is
not far from where i am standing and
also
wrote out the storm here in lake charles
omar good morning to you
what are the conditions like where you
are
good morning tony the storm slammed into
us overnight and the wind was so
violent we could actually feel our hotel
shaking we could hear the building
groaning
and things were slamming against our
window and we were six
stories up and this is just the
beginning of what many fear
could be a deadly storm
after days of anticipation
hurricane laura ripped into louisiana's
coast and beyond overnight
packing 150 mile per hour winds as it
made landfall
this building was torn to shreds it's
windy
and it's wet and things are blowing fast
10 to 15 inches of rainfall are expected
in some areas
and the national weather service said
the storm surge could be
unsurvivable in certain places as it
threatens to push
up to 40 miles inland
before laura made landfall noaa
hurricane hunters flew through the storm
visible via satellite as it churned
toward the gulf coast
where more than half a million people
were under evacuation orders
if you are here you're going to have to
hunker down we spoke with lake charles
mayor nick hunter
hours before the hurricane slammed his
city
he told us it'll be a challenge to
respond to the storm victims
who stayed behind there's going to be a
window where the desire is there
to go and and give people
services and we can't do it it's just
not safe
to give you an idea of how bad they're
expecting things to get here over in
vermilion parish
officials told people there who decided
to hunker down and ride the storm out
some simple instructions get a piece of
paper write your name your social
security number and your next of kin
and put it in a ziploc bag because if
they find you dead they want to know who
they found
and who to contact to tell them you are
no longer alive
tony all right omar thank you very much
you stay safe where you are
one of the big concerns going into this
storm from meteorologists was the storm
surge we are 30 miles from the coast
but that surge could push inland past us
as many as 40 miles in and then the
storm itself
with intense intense wind and tornadoes
could push
still further from there so i want to go
to jonathan vigliotti
who is about 100 miles from the coast in
manny louisiana jonathan good morning to
you
what are you seeing where you are yeah
tony good morning to you you know our
southern bureau chief scott keenan is
going to give me a ring because earlier
today i told him i didn't think the
storm was going to be this strong this
far
up north here in central louisiana and i
was wrong so scott
i'm sorry we have about 130 mile per
hour gus
at times as the eye wall makes its way
over us
you can see the wind and the rain
ripping through these trees
and tony it's important to point out
unlike where you are by the coast the
homes here are not
built to withstand this kind of
sustained wind
for this long the concern here this
morning is twofold of course
the wind there are tornado warnings in
effect wind gusts powerful enough to
flip over cars
and mobile homes and bring down trees
and of course power lines with them and
then of course all the rain when all
said and done
we're expecting up to 10 inches to be
dumped here that is going to cause
flash flooding we've been riding out
this storm in a hotel
packed with evacuees from the coast
along with them first responders once
the storm passes through they will hit
the roads to clear them of any debris
and of course all of those trees so
other emergency personnel can make their
way in to assess the damage
i can tell you right now that the
governor has uh has let out all
of the national guard they will be here
to assess the damage and if the power
outages here
are any indication they have their work
cut out for them more than 300 000
people in the dark including us we just
lost our power
tony back to you all right jonathan
thank you very much believe it or not
the wind that we are still experiencing
here in lake charles is the tail end of
this storm it made landfall around
cameron louisiana and is now tracking
inland to get more on where this storm
may go next let's go to lonnie quinn
who's tracking it from new york lonnie
good morning to you what can people
inland expect
okay good morning to you tony and good
morning everybody
inland it's just getting to you right
now it's about 100 the center of the
storm is about 100 miles
inland right now as we speak it came on
shore you know you were telling us tony
it was around cameron sure enough as a
category 4
150 mile per hour winds well as of right
now
and again it's a hundred miles inland
you still have winds that are blowing
this is an updated number
105 miles per hour so it's a category
two but it's been over land for a
hundred miles
and you still have a category two the
only thing that i have that's good to
report about this storm
is the forward progress it's always been
moving at 15 or 16 miles per hour
a lot of these storms will creep through
an area three four miles per hour
that's the only the only good thing i
have to report
now in terms of the storm surge all
right the winds
at the coast you've had your toughest
winds already at the coast the rain
well you're you're kind of done with the
heaviest rain that coast but the storm
surge is just getting started this is
lake charles that skinny red line shows
you where the storm surge is we are just
now going into major flooding the reason
is even though the storm is north of you
the circulation is still
pushing that water onshore we've got a
few more hours of some bad storm surge
guys let's go back to you
all right lonnie thank you very much i
want to give people another perspective
on the wind and rain battered louisiana
coast as we await
dawn here so let's go to errol barnett
who is in kinder louisiana that was just
outside the eye wall errol good morning
to you
well tony as you can see we're still
feeling the effects of hurricane laura
in fact at this casino which is one of
the largest
in the state it lost power overnight
so we're now joining 11 000 other people
in the county who do not have
electricity
right now and as this hurricane made
landfall
it made for a very uneasy night for
people in this state
our phones buzzing with tornado alerts
and high wind warnings as well in fact
as the hurricane made landfall
it flipped an rv in lake charles that's
about 40 miles from where we are
right now winds were up to 150
miles an hour making it the most
powerful hurricane
to hit this part of the state
[Music]
errol barnett forest reporting from
kinder louisiana and gail and anthony as
i toss it back to you
i will leave you with a reminder that we
are still 20 minutes or so before
sunrise here
along the gulf coast which means we
cannot yet
fully assess the scope of this damage
but what we do know
at this hour is that this is believed to
be the strongest storm to hit this
region
on record boy tony thank you very much
we'll come back to you a little bit
later on he painted quite a picture
anthony
the thing was so ferocious it sounded
like earl burnett lost his accent when
you're screaming that thing is so
very frightening just blew it away no
these these pictures are really scary
and
we haven't even begun to see what this
storm has done yes yes it's not even
daylight there yet